hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am catching up
on the nintendo direct full showcase
before we jump into this i just want to
say there will be some cuts in this
video for if there are ads or if there
are things that i don't have a ton to
say about because there's always a few
things in a nintendo direct that don't
grab me as much so we'll just like jump
around a tiny bit but should have most
of it in here um i should note that i
know about the
uh mario
movie and some of the casting
a new rpg is in the cards
welcome to voice of cards
[Music]
this looks pretty
[Music]
what a card game video
card based video games lately
at the queen's behest you'll set off on
a fantastical journey to slay a fearsome
dragon for honor and fortune
everything in this realm
presented as cards from the protagonists
to shops
and
towns
in this fresh take on tabletop rpgs
very often
oh it is just
literally a bit of luck a virtual
tabletop
works real well for magic the gathering
and pokemon a spellbinding experience
from the creative minds of yokotaro
i'm sorry it's your kotaro
what
he's one of my favorites
what
it actually does look
extremely neo
i should not have been
surprised by that available today on
nintendo eshop cool
even the music
very good
god breath of the wild so good
what a video game you know
how do they just keep making good zeldas
like you'd think at some point
well okay there are something aren't
that good but
a lot of real bangers you're pretty good
for a little kid we'd better partner up
on this don't you think
[Music]
this is a very good trailer
link
[Music]
i feel like this implies a lot of story
that i do not expect to be in
the age of calamity expansion pause for
hyrule warriors this looks more like
what i expected
oh my god
that's super cool
neat
you have to see it
ready
set
chocobo
start your engines and get set for a new
racing experience oh my gosh race is
familiar final fantasy characters like
chocobo and gilgamesh to be the first to
cross the finish oh my gosh oh
i love him so much
myself by using drift boost to cut
corners oh my god
magical stones called magicites are
contained inside items so it's so it's
mario kart magic like fire and arrow
which i'm okay with
acquire magicites of the same element to
cast even more powerful spells
[Music]
has this been announced before today
i don't keep up to date with the latest
news as fast as i should anymore because
it's not my job
it's nice to not have to honestly
um engine customization options will be
available oh my god online multiplayer
i'm so down up to 64 players can compete
in a bracket style tournament to
determine the racing champion
64. gp races exclusively onto nintendo
switch next year i will take it
i'm good with it i don't care if it's
just mario kart i'll take my mario kart
oh you are next we had the same mario
kart for like a
smash decade ultimate oh hello
i have not had this spoiled for me mr
sakurai the game's director will reveal
this fighter in the final mr sakurai
presents
that's just rude
he'll also show you how to use this
fighter so please look forward to it
thank you i will i appreciate that but
also i don't know why you even needed to
mention it the game was released
this will be the last presentation about
super smash brothers ultimate i hope
you'll check it out
it makes sense but that feels very weird
next please take a look at this
what is this
is was it you doing that because it was
pretty cool
the last of his part three now on
nintendo switch
right
i'm interested
i do love copy
hello cutie
i wonder what kind of gameplay that's
not what i was expecting
all right
[Music]
i'm very into this thus far
[Music]
is it like this looks like a platformery
[Music]
i see okay
it's gonna be
3d platformer
adventure vibes
[Music]
i love it
[Music]
very mario 64.
banjo
oh my gosh that's such a good idea
[Music]
god cubbies just just a blessing
that was cool
[Music]
i just wish nintendo games didn't look
so pixelated around the edges
um yes very down
that looks great
is there a release date
thank you i appreciate that answered
immediately very kind of you thank you
nintendo
that was the trailer for kirby and the
forgotten land i love it
in this new game you can freely move
around in 3d areas using newer kirby
moves
the setting also appears to be
mysterious i agree it does with
abandoned structures from a past
civilization again philosophers part
three unexpected
face there i didn't see that the first
time
in spring 2022.
yeah joel really took on a new aesthetic
in the afterlife
it looks amazing we have this to show
you
please take a look
the conferences are so
odd sometimes i love a nintendo direct
it's always oh oh my
a crossing of animals
i feel like we haven't had that many
updates to see it
the roost
oh you got chickens now
i put 400 hours into this game
400.
okay
it is weird that they keep doing this
telling us when we're going to get
updates
crossing new horizons
has been enjoyed by many players around
the world it's true it was very
successful for you new free content will
arrive in november
in preparation for its release we will
be airing an animal crossing new
horizons direct in october
in it we'll go over the content in more
detail
a beloved star wars game is coming to
nintendo switch
blast off to captivating planets looks
pretty much the same jedi droids and
outcasts in this blend of action role
playing and adventure
i'm down the force for good or will you
it actually seems like a great game to
play on the switch your choices
determine the galaxy's fate in star wars
knights of the old republic very good
nintendo switch november 11. cool
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
i have this terrible habit of just
repeatedly buying you must always
remember games that i've already played
on the switch though i really need stuff
this looks like dying light stronghold
against a virus that turns people into
the undead in the clouds this is dying
light okay
i thought it said something else on
screen so i was confused
rpg explore alone ooh interesting it's
cloud-based online co-op as you unravel
the dark secrets of those in power
during the day cool then plunder the
layers of the infected at night i'm
really looking forward to this game
we'll shape the story
but they'll also have consequences
no matter where your creations lead you
physical world evolution stuff is what
i'm the most interested in i hope that
it does
but it pans out take the prequel on the
go in dying light platinum and dying
light is very good you should play it if
you haven't already i highly recommend
it and it holds up it's fantastic
super fun apocalyptic open world
dying light to stay human cloud version
launches on nintendo switch february 4th
2020 interesting oh a demo demo we'll
also it's great same day we have a free
demo
platinum edition comes to nintendo
switch october 19th great pre-orders
begin today on nintendo eshop
don't think that would be my choice of
why to play dying light but i love it
you'll respect it morality or liberty
in triangle strategy a fiery chronicle
of war presented in stunning hd2d
that is pretty actions will lead you
through a riveting scene this looks like
um what's it called
in the end
you think
in response to the survey about the demo
released in february of this year the
game has been fine-tuned with a focus on
elements that receive okay so i guess
this is already something everybody
knows about i don't remember this either
the difficulty i'm just so behind now
now that i work in
game development
when your whole life is
making video games to review previous
dialogue
i'm way less up to date which is kind of
nice because it means all of these are
surprises whereas like when i worked in
games media i was like yeah i know i've
already seen this yodo and now i'm like
oh cool new thing all the time on
nintendo.com
it's very pretty triangle strategy will
launch a nintendo switch march 4th 2012.
i feel like i will play that thank you i
appreciate that nintendo means a lot to
me
i will not pre-order it but still thank
you for the offer
nice
oh
dre
officially on the switch
are we gonna see are we gonna see more
than that
oh man
i really like the art style not that
metroid hasn't always had fantastic art
styles
there may be a very small opportunity
for this game that's so cool
ooh i like that
he's a big boy
a lot of crawly crawly guys out here huh
i'm noticing a theme
samus aaron the most powerful bounty
hunter i've been saying iran my whole
life and you just said aaron to the
uncharted planet zdr what
confirm whether the deadly x parasite
still exists and figure out why the emmy
research robots in search of it have
mysteriously
real alien vibes
early readings reveal that planet zdr is
divided into alcohol environments
each with its own elements yes good
and all
remnants of the mighty chozo
civilization are also scattered
throughout including evidence that the
children may have once called
their home it looks like an elite
metroid.nintendo.com to read metroid
report volume 8 for a detailed account
of the terrain
and life forms you may encounter hell
yeah
be sure to view the other metroid dread
reports there as well
you'll want to prepare yourself for the
dangers that lie ahead i am looking
forward to it metroid
launches on nintendo switch october 8th
it's very soon are available now on
nintendo eshop
sign me up how was that
good thank you i don't nintendo switch
on why are you asking me
okay i've been using nintendo switch
online since it launched in september we
have yeah unfortunately true in addition
to the current membership we'll be
adding a new membership plan okay
offering what as a part of this new
plans content
hello my love
how are you today
you'll be able to play a collection of
nintendo 64 games
the nintendo 64 system launched 25 years
ago oh my love i think this system gave
many players their first 3d gaming
experience for me
as well as intense four-player
multiplayer action also true nintendo
switch up to four people can play select
nintendo 64. dude i love the 64 mario
tennis
oh my god i love this
also with this new membership plan in
addition to the nintendo how do they
keep getting memes
no way that's cool
you can play a collection of games from
sega's genesis system
amazing
[Music]
the new plan will include all elements
of the base nintendo switch online
membership
so you can only access to play the
included nintendo 64 in genesis games
these 64 games if you upgrade your
membership nintendo switch online
expansion pack is a smart way to do that
but wait you can't buy them
or play them
otherwise
you have an existing membership plan can
change over to the new plan okay noted
thank you
of course you'll still be able to
continue using the existing plans
interesting existing membership plan can
change over to the new plan okay
we'll share more details about this new
membership plan at a later time
including i have questions
for now however we'd like to announce
the games that will be available when it
launches
you'll be able to play the nintendo 64
game shown here oh my god
oh wow
these genesis games gotta get your echo
the dolphin man you gotta do it we'll
also continue adding more nintendo 64
games such as the legend of zelda
majora's mask and f-zero x hell yeah
dude nintendo 64 and genesis games going
forward oh my god
my heart
people mario banjo-kazooie
furthermore you love to see it i love
that the banjo is still
available and that wasn't that what same
style controls what from their original
releases
i'm sorry what did you say both can be
used wirelessly
releasing a wireless n64 controller just
by any nintendo switch online listen
it's a horrific controller but oh my god
we hope you'll look forward what
plan do you think that they'll release a
bunch of them plus expansion pack like
they did back in the day like i can get
my let's see pokemon stadium one
can we have pokemon stadiums
how's everything
good thank you a few more announcements
in today's nintendo ds okay cool
oh miyamoto-san hello miyamoto what
brings you in i wanted to make an
announcement so i was hoping i could
step in did you oh of course did you my
friend what kind of announcement you're
trying to make hi everyone
hello shigeru
previously announced that i have been
working with the hollywood movie studio
illumination yes ceo and producer chris
ah this is going to be the film
despicable me and sync in making a
full-length animated mario movie for the
big screen yep
today this hair looks really nice
theatrical release timing oh i didn't
know the release date
okay that's late next year the movie
will be released in theaters and holiday
2022. holiday is such a weird way to
place that north america is on december
great cool thanks i appreciate that take
it back
means a lot
at a later time wow
longer until we can share a glimpse so
they are in action on the big screen
members who will be voicing mario and
his friends in the movie
first of course
who will be played
could you come with charles marlin but
they went with chris pratt mario will be
talking a lot in the movie okay please
look forward to mario as performed by
the very talented who's now just
american the
next this one i think is very good
taylor joy that does work she's peaches
for sure
it definitely works
mario's little brother luigi will be
played i thought that those were memes i
saw those on twitter i didn't think that
was real to see this timid sibling
appear on screen
that works as well i also love jackpot
jack black it's great i love it
a monster performance by jackson very
good very good very good
the comedian oh no way it's key
what
i'm looking forward to oh my gosh
this is probably gonna be pretty funny
though this is a mario movie also
thought that was a meme making an
appearance
he will be played by seth rogen i can
kind of see the voice working eager for
you to see a humorous donkey kong by
satsang
and of course charles martinez what is
he doing who has voiced mario and many
more nintendo he has in our games what
about him
is also involved
in huawei will be appearing in surprise
cameos in the movie interesting
i've met him
um and he was wonderful oh my gosh
to play some of our other beloved
characters friend thomas and his cranky
kong oh my god
what the hell man i mean it all works
it's just very unexpected
we've all been coming up with all sorts
of ideas and oh my god i'm enjoying a
creative process that is a little bit
different from making games yeah a
little bit while until we can share more
updates but i hope you'll look forward
to it thank you miyamoto i appreciate
that back to you
oh my gosh i can't believe it
please look forward to mario's adventure
jumping into the world of motion
pictures is that what it's called
mario's adventure or is it just super
mario bros we'd like to show you this
okay
is it you clicking again
ah splatoon
i have not played splatoon in a while
i'm not very good at it but it's a great
game oh that's neat
how very halo of you
cool
damn
[Music]
[Music]
this looks rad
what an update
oh my
okay not what i expected not what i
thought that whatever this was would
look like
what
in spite of us
what
this is very strange
okay
yeah cool
[Music]
maybe it makes more sense to people
who've played more splatoon than me but
i'm currently like wow are you trying to
brainwash me
is this like a
that makes a rattler um like a clockwork
orange type situation where i'm supposed
to remember this imagery or something
it's splatoon 3
oh
oh that makes sense i was like wow huge
steps forward
i didn't expect that
okay neat
very cool
that makes a lot more sense than that
being a dlc oh
i'm sorry
i'm a researcher from the squid research
lab i've been meticulously studying the
mysterious squids okay nintendo
transform into human form the shows are
never boring
even if you don't get announcements that
you want
never boring
please look forward to more
splatoon 3. oh my god thank you though
weird but thank you
oh my gosh why did that happen
i'm okay with it but but strange
so
what did you think
i had a good time splatoon 3 taking
place in a new world yeah is scheduled
to release in 2022. they have a good
lineup of 2022 releases already then
please press that forward to future
updates thank you
you can't tell me what to look forward
to so the last trailer we have to show
you today what am i expecting from this
i have no idea
platinum did somebody say platinum
oh
who's it going to be
hello
anti-tank rockets so that's uh
that's a monster of some kind
look at this cool guy he [ __ ] for sure
oh my
and there's two of them
the military in these games always
useless never accomplish anything no
point don't know why you keep trying
what did you think the bullets were
gonna work on whatever the [ __ ] this is
what
oh my god
that's what i thought there she is
hell yeah
absolute queen
[Music]
yes good yes
it seems i'm unfashionably late
but i'm ready to give you but it makes
me so happy
ah god i feel so strongly about the way
platinum does combat
and that like their animations are
beautiful
but they're so fast
like they really make sure that they
favor
reaction times above anything else
they're so specific about
the exact amount of seconds it's
supposed to take
um after you press a button for
something to happen and they nail it i
love platinum combat
yes
incredible
i do wish it looked a little bit less
dull graphically but
i understand
oh my
that's my worst nightmare
but at least it's helping
for i will play every game platinum
makes for the rest of my life so there's
that
and this one is no different and i love
it
i expected that too
it's been a good showcase a lot of 2022
stuff
oh [ __ ]
damn
what you just saw was the latest trailer
for bayonetta i love it
we announced this game in 2017. you sure
did thank you for your patience you sure
sure did it will launch next year
i doubt it though maybe it
thank you i do
i really do
that's all for today's nintendo direct
that was a good time i had fun
thank you
hey i got you the next one when i say
october 10
i think they said
yeah that was fun
definitely enjoyed it um
yeah there'll be some cuts in this video
for ads or like things that i didn't
have a lot to say about but uh
out of three man
that rules i'm i'm such a big fan of
them and uh
yeah i conveniently had like almost none
of this spoiled for me i didn't get
bayonetta spoiled for me it should have
made sense to me because one of my
friends um
posted
a picture of her bayonetta cosplay
but i didn't put two and two together
uh very good thank you all for joining
me as i watch this nintendo direct and
we'll see you guys next time bye